Yello good morning millenials oh my gosh
welcome back feels like it's been so
much it happened like last night this
morning right
Megan Marco well I just looked at the
timing we'll talk about negative arco
but like I love how they don't care like
about Americans cuz they announced it I
like 4:00 in the morning yeah woke up it
was like I was met so early I missed it
but no it was like 6:00 and I was
singing the same thing a lot especially
my teens I was like I can't care about
this yet but I guess in Britain they
already care and it's 10:30 here do you
care about Megan Markel yet it's 10:30
here do you know where Megan Merkel's
children are I do any hair grow in her
belly um but it's we're just saying
Megan Marko and belly because she really
like oh okay round a belly girl
People magazine this morning six tricks
Megan Markel used to hide her pregnancy
I'm like there's just one [ __ ] it's
called being skinny and also loving
naturally thin and you don't really look
pregnant and chile's Markel is really
like screwing things up for her right
really helped her in the genetics
department and this is really um first
of all you know and he has a conspiracy
not a conspiracy like he says that
there's a royal surrogate that's cain't
used for her third child the first two
and that Megan would use because she is
very thin and and older that you might
have a hard time getting pregnant so I
don't know if it's legit or not that
could be that could be one of the tricks
People magazine was alluding to but uh
surrogacy perhaps but she got married
seven months ago I feel like they
wouldn't turn to surrogacy at seven
months I know like that would be after a
few years of no success but I have to
think that if you marry a prince like
they test your fertility before that oh
for sure you even test fertility yeah
a lot of people rate the car - and
everything I know about women's health
comes from the Kardashian totally they
should partner up with Planned
Parenthood they partner up with a Part
II didn't watch last night's episode but
they run it up when those into the end
there were so many partnerships of
course like and the partners on the show
were also the commercials airing it was
all very sooner ties - Jack Donaghy
would say well that's vertical
integration if I've ever seen I also
learned a lot about business from 30
rock and Shark Tank of course and the
morni don't I learn a lot about
businesses like about dub is like
showbiz okay 30 rock okay I've been
watching 30 rock with Zack and we can't
agree so it's it's loosely based on like
NBC SNL yep is Tina Fey supposed to be
playing Tina Fey or like the Lauren
Michael's look neither more so the Lord
Michael that's what I said because Jack
Donaghy's nothing Lorne Michaels and
Jack Donaghy are not it's no person Jack
Donaghy's supposed to be like a cheese
we don't know
yeah bigwig who like is predation yeah
it's not it's not really the show girl
the girlie show was supposed to be like
a failing SNL for women right and then
they only couldn't succeed with a man
right
and yes it's loosely based off that but
I don't think specific characters are
meant to reflect over your life people I
don't even think Tina Fey's supposed to
be born but let me jog the Lord the job
yeah okay someone need to tell Zach he
obviously won't see the show but someone
to tell them do I hear the weirdest
saying that's last night that just was
so pertinent of course we were watching
Kardashians and they were playing um
Kardashian softball versus the Jackson's
and so when he saw Jackson's he's like
Jackson is that like Shahs of Sunset I
was like your first thought about
Jackson is Shahs of Sunset castmates
illegitimate the husband baby daddy hey
Michael it's not Janet it's a Latoya
it's not Paris totally awesome I so
interest he's keeping up he's in to know
for sure you're doing a good job you
know that means you're doing a good job
at home thank you you're keeping a happy
home well I wasn't here on Friday cause
me and snitch headed down to the ATL and
and I wasn't here on Friday either
because of the great migraine of 2018
that's in essence 24 hours but so many
things happened in Atlanta that like I
don't even know where to start and
obviously me and Margo were actually
I've never even told mark of this but I
was pretty good I was planning on
vlogging the whole experience and doing
a video for our patreon cuz we do five
episodes a month and sometimes we do
videos instead of podcast and somebody
requested like jamming up on Eocene and
behind the scenes yeah someone requested
a behind the scenes of like life on tour
and literally when we got to the hotel
after like a treacherous to have travel
which would have been great material
like I remembered I'm Margo you don't
even know that she were asleep I took
like one video of you sleeping and it's
very long and then I was like
remembering I was like okay I'll do it
when I start getting ready and obviously
I forgot so this is not the trip and I'm
gonna clean on this week so I mean
that'll be the trip that I remember
Margo it's your job now we should do
Boston she hosts the video of Margo
sleeping like just for Peter and people
like free of charge because it's so
funny um
yeah you should do Boston Freddie
machines and then we'll also do a behind
the scene slash music video oh god
that's just me can you guys and I'm so
out of shape it's this weekend that's
why the group chat was popping off this
morning when Margot Lewin texted it you
know Jackie O no mo week but you know
what it is it's like I've so much to do
before I get to them I have so much
weight to lose I got a list of I chose
to play planes to take lips to acts and
machines to clean up eyebrows to acts
like I haven't waxed my eyebrows since
August well I let me just run through
Atlanta really quickly because there's
so many things I have to say I mean the
Briella that all debris l oh that's
that's not even where I can't even start
there because like so much happened
before okay this was okay I played one
theater before and when I say theater I
mean like theater cuz it was only 500
seats and it was old as hell and the
name is kind of controversial the
oriental theater like how embarrassing
for me no kidding
but then in Atlanta I played like my
real first theater and I was really
happy because I'm playing Boston in two
weeks which is like it's supposed to be
like the tipping point of my wide but
the Atlanta show was the same amount of
people so I was like it was my first
time practicing in front of a thousand
and seventy five people and it was so
different like you don't understand like
I can't go back to a comedy club ever
again is better well for a million
reasons like you can't see faces from
afar why you can't and sometimes I
really like to read people's faces and
like engage with them but sometimes it's
nice to like not have to see if people
are having a good time and just think
that they are yeah and because there's
monitors and speakers around me I can't
really hear the audience so I'm like I'm
just assuming they're having a good time
which is just like a huge weight lifted
off my Sunday's you hear the laughter
right children's laughed and me and
Margo like we walked from the dressing
room to the stage like the stage was
huge Marga made the best call it was
literally like High School Musical like
the side stage the ropes the lights like
there was literally five million people
working at the venue just like to make a
stage work it was just it was such a
different experience and it was like
girl talent yes no I felt like a real
true comedian like the only thing on
stage was like the mic and I would say
it like to fans like me in the mic it
was so crazy and just like so wonderful
and then I I invited Heather McMann and
Brielle and I didn't know if both them
said they were coming by the people say
they're coming and then they lie all the
time so like I
no if they were really gonna come and
sometimes it really gets in my head if I
like no people are coming so I gave them
Argos phone number and I had her
coordinate and I just like didn't really
want to know if they came or not it's
something going on on your phone that's
like more interesting than what I'm
saying sorry now are you sure yeah I'm
just being distracted by the comments
just looking at myself don't know them I
haven't looked in a mirror in a few days
I'm just like okay feeling myself I'm
sharing my feelings and I really would
appreciate if you were listening so I
don't really like to know flirt
counsellors listening I don't really
like to know if like people that I know
are in the audience like friends okay
just it gets in my head like when Ben's
parents came to my studio everything
through their lens how are they judging
what I'm saying right and like I just
one joke about how atoms act to cut you
want to thank you I just wonder about
hand jobs and I'm my favorites Ben's
parents are here yeah like things like
that
so I've started to just like invite
people and then like not find out if
they're actually coming and just like
let snitch and alive so counsellors met
channels everything everything and I had
like I played don't be tardy like I just
like it was real specific cuz there's a
lot of like Atlanta chick-fil-a you
didn't know if she was there in the
audience so I do it but I guess the
jokes are pertinent because you're in
Atlanta right right so when the show was
over the show is great the audience was
just so Alex Rios day and it was in this
part of Atlanta called Sandy Springs and
it was so [ __ ] rich like it was a
20-minute driving we just like drove
past mansions like manche manche manche
in Manchester I'm peachy
no I'm Margot bubs it was a pound Vernon
Mount Vernon Highway
well you look at memory snitch you know
dementia for you I guess it doesn't run
in our family it's just like I think
it's nice with and so it was so great
everything was wonderful then the show
was over and I had like 20 minutes
before me and greet and I was in the
dressing room and Margo brought back
everyone who came and so many things
happened first of all Brielle came and
it was just like the moment of my life I
came first and she came with Slade and
her friend who was so nice and funny and
it was she's back together with her man
I assume yeah I assume yeah and I was
just asking so many questions about job
HRT I was being son Ryan is the holding
a shot they're waiting for real estate
she said probably December and I was
just like I'm Kim so then she facetimes
Kim and Kim was like why don't you bring
me and I was like I gave real four
tickets because I was like and she only
brought three people so I was like can
you could have come and Kim is getting a
massage and I was honestly being like a
thirst monster for Kim I was like you
should get a massage you worked so hard
so Thursday absolutely all I said I was
like I love you so much like I will
support you no matter what you do like
even when you're crazy like I love you
and she was like thank you so much she
was so nice and so funny and they have
like a very funny rapport that's so cute
and she was very cool she hung for 20
minutes had some snacks and then I went
to meet greet and she left before she
thought to either McMahon came with her
sister and here's the thing never met
Heather exam before I've never met
Heather McMahon before and everyone is
like you have to have the McMahon you're
gonna love her and when people tell me
that like people love to tell me about
their friends were like ruined people
for you and they also are like oh she's
so funny she's also a comedian like
you're gonna love her and I'm like well
the odds of me liking someone who might
be my competition are very slim so like
nine times out of ten like if you tell
me to like someone I will [ __ ] hate
them and honestly I was ready to hate
how to me fan I'm like everyone loves
her like I'm gonna prove them wrong
Jackie and love her so much like I just
first of all there's so many things I
love about her she's the funniest woman
alive she is so finally Sharon Lee had a
funnier person or like been around such
funny oh sorry I mean you're so funny
she's really a different kind of and
she's not your competition no not at all
and she and even if she was like she's
better than me I'm like she deserves all
of her success she's so funny and she
came with her sister so it was likes
teeny sister vibes like nothing like
since Tina and I tell you she's like
such like a nice supportive girl like
she was like literally just like being
so nice the whole time like even after
the show was over me when I don't you
that couldn't stop talking about my show
it was so nice and like I don't know if
she was just doing only to make me feel
good but like it was working and she was
being so funny so we went and she was
just like helping to carry my [ __ ] like
she was just being so helpful and so we
went to those broad shoulders she'll
tell you she went to his place of
Clermont lounge I told her I'm like I
want to go like authentic experience ATL
she's like okay we have to go to
Clermont lounge and honestly it sounded
like stuck-up like like a country club
but I didn't want that but I was like
right but other bands wonderful for a
grand mal a midnight in ATL I was in
going to the country club Clermont
lounge in the Clermont hotel I was like
oh my god this is gonna be like [ __ ]
Four Seasons vibes and that's not what I
wanted and it was literally the opposite
of what I expected first of all it was
literally like a bar in a dungeon which
is like my favorite just like with neon
signs and like Bud Light and it was a
strip club and I say strip club cuz like
it wasn't really a strip club it was
just like there were strippers on the
bar
I guess like part of this charm of the
of the club is that the strippers are
like senior citizens and there were a
couple like a couple 35 there were a
couple 25 year-old to let weren't
working hard because they thought they
didn't have to do you know any wow I
wasn't impressed with them and like I
wanna shiver with something to prove
right so I had taken out like literally
200 dollars in anything else cuz like me
and Margo were like ready to go and
Heather was being so funny cuz like the
girls who were like young and tight like
they just felt like they didn't have to
really even take off their clothes or
work whereas like these grandmother's
like I saw a vision of grandmother like
so but the young girls like they didn't
think they have to work for it and
Heather was like making the best point
she was like this young girl is wearing
wedges like that's how little mud that's
how little she thinks she has to try
just because she's young I didn't give
her any money and she was coming of it
where did you see that it's on your lip
what was that I think it's breakfast
what you have I didn't looks like my
tooth actually are they all there oh
there's a little chip stop Wow well
that's new and whatever Heather was just
so great like I everyone pushed her on
me and they were right like I'm
obsessing her and I didn't have a
[ __ ] picture with her or her phone
number and I'm so annoyed but like I
don't have to get it be it that's when
you know it's real yeah and then me my
friend didn't I go on a Krispy Kreme umm
she's moving to New York in the way the
Italian stallion uh-huh and she's
getting married in Italy we gotta go we
gotta go
I never been I'm just trying to like
make I was trying to extent that were
just like assuming that I would be
invited you don't even but like you like
with destination weddings it's like if
you care enough to cross the pond for me
like you can if you care enough till I
get a passport right you're welcome to
get a passport scam yeah but it was just
it was so wild I mean just like such
I've just been traveling so much like
literally in the same pair of leggings
and now not dirty jeans no I travel in
leggings oh my god are you crazy
travels in jeans not me do you Margo
know been like lays around the house and
jeans it's the weirdest that's so weird
but I literally wear the same pair of
leggings and like and then we're just
going to the Bahamas and we're Jackies
about Charette we're going to Miami I
think we're going to Cleveland and I'm
going to clean done like I just so many
trips coming up and so many like moments
where I'm like sitting in the same
sweater pair of pants that are like
sweaty like I really feel like I'm gonna
get a UTI well if you feel like you're
gonna
you ti do you know there's a new thing
called you Cora out where it's
preventative UT I like medical bill no
if you like mix it with your water and
you drink it it tastes like pink
lemonade apparently it's like so
delicious and there's nothing really out
there that like prevents UTIs except for
this like people say drink cranberry
juice right and never never works and if
Regina George taught us anything it's
that you just helps makes you gain
weight right like that the sugar yeah I
really want to lose 3 pounds no I know
so you need to get yourself Saudi hora I
don't know this is me or like I run like
I live in constant fear of getting a UTI
well because the thing about UTIs is
they are so painful but so easy to
capture like once that's coming on you
just have to ride it out you have to
ride out the pain there's no way to stop
it until now
yeah and like the hot pee that comes
along with it that's the worst part oh
no the feeling like you're gonna have
hot pho the feeling that you have to pee
and then like you go and you run and you
don't oh my god that's actually gonna
happen to me like always now that I
think about it but then when you
actually do pee it's like 7 million
degrees that's the worst part of a UTI
well get yourself some you core if you
really think that's gonna happen you
should just drink it on the plane you
get it you can get it online and you can
get you Cora and say goodbye to UTI is
right now you Cora is offering 30% off
when you text toast to 48 48 48 but
hurry this is a limited time offer text
toast to 48 48 48 to get 30% off of your
order of you Cora that's tio ast 2 4 8 8
for 8 for 8 couldn't have been easier
couldn't have been easier and you know
you better get that you should say I
like love Crystal Light so I feel like I
might be down for this
no like you will be drinking your
beverage of choice and people always put
a staving off in fact outer supplements
like for their muscles in there like
water bottles like I should just do them
and people are gonna think I'm like
juicing for the gym I'm like a merman do
you guys I do that all the time and say
it's electrolytes or you know what tell
them what it is yeah to be ashamed of
it's like woman a fellow woman will
understand what you're doing and a man
only should ever experience such pain oh
I wish men like get what's it like
what's that thing like kidney stones
we're like women to see them out and
then like have to get surgery no you
they can pass for a man - I know they
have - I get them surgically she always
had them in friends and make joey
camasta versa
I was like wow you know a lot about him
um no no but yes I just like have this
concept here of you Chad's just because
I'm traveling so much and I'm gonna be
in a bathing suit like for a month oh my
god I'm so nervous we gotta get spray
tans no we okay here's what the list of
what we have to do okay and let's do it
we're getting Botox on Tuesday we are
yeah I mean on the phone I don't have to
do a confirm today okay I know that we
were going to say because I've been like
going back and forth and like we're just
doing it all so like all of a sudden my
botox was gone like I was starting to
feel like I was having lines and now my
forehead is just back to what it was
which is a piece of trash I like my
forehead was so premium what I was
trying to do this wait as long as
possible before the wedding but maybe
I'll just get it now and then get it
again before the weddings like I don't
want people to know what I'm feeling
oh my gosh they can imagine okay so um
Botox we're getting eyebrows a hundred
percent and my lip I know you are blonde
so god loves you more and doesn't but I
have like a fear that I have a mustache
and no one will tell I will tell you you
know by the way I would agree that's
true no I've never noticed it and mine
is so bad these days that like my makeup
is really like starting to concentrate
around the follicles on my lip that like
my makeup it's making it worse now they
sense when I was getting ready for my
show in O Atlanta my makeup was so bad
and all I could look at was my [ __ ]
mouth - are you doing yourself
yeah I've started to only do it myself
because they're performing like these
huge theater is I'm getting so bit of a
hair Oh Kate Middleton how humble am I
know it cuz it's like if I ever get the
resources to like bring hair and makeup
with me I'm not gonna spend it on hair
makeup because I'm good enough at it I'm
gonna spend it on personal security in
first class
Oh corner cyphers class well that's why
Delta and so we get upgraded I get
upgraded and the travel comes out of
like my bottom line so like I always
book um coach and then I get upgraded a
couple days before and if I don't then
I'll upgrade myself but like and it's an
image thing you know like I can't have
people like seeing me on tour sitting in
coach then they think my tour is a
failure right you know but and then the
intern sits standby right okay so when
we buy Margo's flights like so are you
okay
mind get booked like that's an advance
cuz I don't book then and they get like
upgraded and I got my medallion my TSA
PreCheck priority oh my god [ __ ]
snitch is up Treacher to travel with she
has no pre check
no priority and I buy her flight so like
anything and no one covers microsites
it's an expense to me so like you know a
homegirl is getting like main cabin
without seat selection it's not even
mean sorry
you got me basic so I don't even get a
seat aside until I get to the gate oh my
god so they'd sign up for pre check in
Atlanta
yes Omar go to the interview but for
pre-chat good but now that Margo is
getting pretty check I did clear I want
to do clear okay let me tell you why
because I've seen it everywhere there's
never a line and I'm like what the [ __ ]
and I know you have to pay for it but
I'm like you know whatever to me so
that's the downside what there seems to
be no downside other than the government
has all of your information it's $200 a
year and if you're of a certain Italian
stance with Delta which now I am because
I've been traveling so much it's only
$79 a year and you can add family
members for only $50 like if you want to
give me $50 I'll add you $50 yeah it's
$200 so basically you do the Machine
everything I signed up online so now
that I'd go for the first time I have to
give them my fingerprint in my face but
then once I finish that basically they
take you to the front of the pre-check
line and I have pre check so I still
have to take on the computer or anything
I don't mind paying the money but for a
while I wasn't traveling that much so
like I wouldn't have done it because if
I didn't travel in like once a year like
who cares or even like Global Entry
mostly I leave the country once a year I
don't need a global entry mm-hmm but I'm
gone every single weekend from now until
the summer the life of a trust game
clear yeah no I'll let you know I'm
gonna use it this week at Kona Cleveland
unfortunately Jackie you can't come but
I'm very excited and I'll let you know
how premium the experience is Cleveland
or clear:both but I was talking about
clear and what started before we jump
into the fester I've had like 7 million
things I want to talk about so let me
just check my list Atlanta Heather
McMann Clermont lounge that's all one
category yeah and then I went to the
theater last night
yes you did I went to Lincoln Center
which I haven't been to since I got
engaged to have like PTSD from like the
night that I wore a romper and wedges
together like I can't even talk about it
like what's wrong with what you are
Jackie what those budgets those get a
little bit just that I literally bore
for six years straight oh I know those
clodhoppers if so do that has a platform
with know like slant yeah is a clock I'm
sure it does have like a 10 degree angle
I'm just in defensively wedges but
whatever I just I hate those pictures
okay they were like really cute like
four five years ago when I was 17 right
and you could clot around right but as a
21 year old
woman getting engaged in Lincoln Center
like how prestigious and and legit is
that like elegant I was the opposite of
elegant that night but that's fine it's
fine whatever
so Ben and I went to God O'Malley at
Lincoln Center and I just have to say
I've seen him once before two years ago
and at Joe's Pub and first of all just
like so impressive how far he's come in
America for the past two years and a lot
of Americans don't know him literally
when me and men were walking in there
with only people speaking English
everyone was speaking Moroccan Arabic
French or Hebrew and he is like they
call him the Jerry Seinfeld of France
and he is like the biggest comedian in
the world but except for America and so
now he's been touring in America for two
years and like he's really doing like a
great job and everyone loves him but
like though the people that come to a
show like our Alicia and her family like
I texted her I'm like ELISA everyone in
this room is related to you someway
somehow
why didn't she go oh well I thought I
thought for sure she was gone because
only reason I know who he is is because
of her of her she had an extra ticket
she said you want to come and I'm like
yeah and it was so funny but like her
and was it the same show it was half and
half like it was some stuff I had heard
cuz he also has a Netflix special and
the thing that we love did the Netflix
special that we watched when we were in
you table at the restaurant he didn't do
which I was like hoping that he would
because it was so funny
but I I thought about something cuz so
what happened was that uh Lucy gave me a
ticket and like it was so funny and like
they were dying cuz like they're
Moroccan and he was born in Casablanca
and like the Moroccan jokes about like
Moroccan dads and their slippers like I
didn't really understand but like they
were dying and so at least he has
brother reo was like going backstage and
he like let us tag along and like we
were just like teenyboppers in the back
just like loving and like Leonardo
DiCaprio was there so like me at least
you were just like dying and you know we
always say we could always stand to be
like a little bit more Thursday yes
here's what happened you were teasing I
wasn't thirsty obviously I was just like
excited to be there and I didn't say
anything
and Italy's his brother Aria was like oh
she's 2 million followers like he was
doing it for me I don't even asked it's
always the best way to go about it right
and then God was like oh that's so cool
and he followed me and then we've kind
of deemed over the past two years and
then he invited me to the show last
night so it was like if REO hadn't done
that and like I wasn't thirsty like I
never would have gotten to experience
the premium experience that was last
night so the lesson is be thirstier kind
of cuz like but thank God for at least
his brother who like stepped in for me
for like being a weenie but like if he
did it like I never would have like had
this friendship with God you know mm-hmm
and I just think everyone should learn
to be a little bit more thirsty like the
girls at my show who literally came in
there like we didn't even have tickets
how did you go to the mean green they're
like we did what you told you and Jackie
told us to just pretend like you an
Adele V the [ __ ] I know what I couldn't
even be mad at them and I was like you
guys have to bet mommy 100 or something
but like it they were like we just
pretended like we had to be here and
they let us into the meat trade I'm like
little tighter well now like everyone's
gonna do that well no because like I
said I'm I'm cutting but it budget for
her to make up in hiring personal
security cuz this girl to me in green
trees I mean snitches and cutting it
what other people who snuck into your
room oh this girl Margo like went to
grab you man bar going to grab Heather
McMann and Brielle and these two girls
came like assuming they were with
Heather or with Brielle because total we
had given them like a ticket yeah and so
like it was I appreciated whatever I
like took a picture but then Margo was
trying to get them to leave and like oh
and also Michelle Cheech came I got a
million comp tickets so like it was hard
to keep track of who was who and Margo
was like okay and like tried to get like
like okay like you got your picture it's
time to go hey just look at me they were
all so drunk and like they just didn't
want to leave in like I asked my Heather
I was like Heather can you get them out
cuz like Heather was perfect for it they
wouldn't listen to anyone what it was so
crazy Margo good good call remember
wow people not listening to Heather like
just a lack of respect lots of respect
but oh I'm saying the show was
phenomenal I learned so much I was
literally taking notes
Ben was dying like I was laughing so
hard he also had an opener whoo I can't
stand openers not your own chauffeurs oh
no he had an opener who was so funny and
like it's really crazy because like we
come from the Internet's like we really
like their thing I feel like I last
night I really realize like ironically
like how kind of PC I am in the sense
that like there's so much I won't say
but this guy's whole 15-minute intro was
about how certain people in New York
there's like a million ways to kill
yourself in New York and it's so
inconvenient for other people I'm like
he's like if you're gonna jump in front
of the subway tracks like we shouldn't
be able to pick you up till 4:00 in the
morning because I could just
inconvenience Inc ten million people on
the subway and like I was like my mouth
was like I was like oh man that's so
[ __ ] up like it was so funny and I was
just like I would never make jokes like
that but like it's a circle that's so
funny and and true right and he was like
if you're just gonna jump off the
building like that's just my luck like
you would hit me and kill me and then
you would survive
Lenny Marcus oh my god he was so funny
so funny put me in like a great mood and
then God was just so funny it's the
physicality he's like literally weighs
90 pounds and like his legs flail all
over the place and he's a
with someone hmm who's the Princess of
Monaco so his son who was like hot and
French Grace Kelly his grandmother is
Grace Kelly Wow it's just the whole
thing was so interesting and he was
talking about it he said yeah I know
like I had a kid hide sex with the
princess like it was so funny and if you
have he's all around the country now and
like he's really it's so crazy he's like
if I go on a date in Morocco like the
girl she knows that loves me he's like
if I go on a date in America like
literally nobody knows who I am and he's
like it has so many celebrities all they
want is a bit of normalcy and they
didn't achieve it in some countries and
others like that's kind of cool no
totally but his jokes were just so funny
he was like like in France like they die
like scream everyone in the room was
French half the show was French half the
show was Algerian who's meaning somebody
jokes that Algeria was so funny and I'm
not even Algerian he did like four shows
it was so impressive no he did like four
shows he was so impressive you did like
English Arabic Moroccan French Hebrew a
little bit and like everyone in the
audience was like I was laughing at the
jokes in French like it was so weird it
was so funny and now he's in doing a
whole American tour like I only want
good things for him like comics
supporting other comics so if you're if
he's coming he's basta and he's doing a
big show in LA like you should go it was
so funny and so premium and everyone
there was so hot it was French people
like hotties that seems like the most
important detail ladies except get after
it
I got seen the next row heckler this old
man when you do when me and Ben were
walking in he was like
scalping for tickets we saw him I'm
gonna got seated next to us it was no
weird that is weird doesn't like being
such a heckler I he was annoying the
[ __ ] out of me he was like nine years
old he looks like Bell's dad from Beauty
and the Beast Maurice I hate Maurice
okay without further ado what's been now
30 minutes of talking about but they
started that was on a sponsored post
forgot O'Malley show people think that
it was it wasn't he's a friend of mine
without further ado here are the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast now this was a big
weekend in the world of news oh my god
Hugh and I'm so excited what's first
okay first is the most breaking
pertinent news focus that Meghan Markel
is pregnant expecting her first child
with Prince Harry this is very exciting
I mean we kind of already spoke about it
after much speculation at the royal
wedding this weekend aka Meghan was
wearing just a loose jacket first
woman why would you do that she's
pregnant she passed her 12-week mark
apparently they told the family at the
wedding this weekend and and it was now
they really did you need to get married
and like take the but Eugenie have her
moment yeah and then make it all about
her again know for sure did you feel
like the world revolves around Meghan
Markel well it definitely revolves
around the royal family and I think like
Meghan Markel she just combined such so
many different things that people are
obsessed with like first of all like
royalty
second of all like Americans served
about celebrity celebrity Deal or No
Deal
Beauty grace how how Cooper Burt sorry
man I literally get English out for a
second that was weird how Cooper she's
had smoochy the black hood yeah that's
me forget oh not a chewin oh she really
knew was here on eclis because she's an
outburst she's awesome
she's the American dream but like of
course the British know but ever even
Americans want to be royalty yeah that's
my like we're obsessed with their credit
Lauren can no no this is so great this
is really sweet
the timing is like so fairytale that
like it has to be fake do you know what
I mean like no one's too perfect right
she's gonna give birth probably on their
one-year anniversary and it's like
that's so you had like three months of
honeymoon bliss yeah nine months of
pregnancy you're gonna like spit out a
baby right she's totally the type of
girl who likes farts out of a ting know
like from the back like she's totally
gonna am a loony and like be pregnant
from the front end not from the back one
of the strippers at the Clermont lounge
actually Lois pregnant the final
stripper that before it was getting sad
and me and Margot were like we have to
go was pregnant and she was one of like
the young really thin pretty ones and
like she turned to the side and we're
like choosing a one-piece lingerie and
I'm like she's pregnant and it should
start to show her boobs and vagina and
I'm like I can learn to see her baby
like please get up I was giving her
money I was like it was a two for one
because you undermined said she
obviously like this money's going for
the child so I literally gave all my
money and then we left that's nice but
it was it was really sad
sure like strip clubs are like fun for
the first five minutes and then like
mystery yo bad aspect and you can take
pictures like not of I don't want to see
pictures of the girls I want to take
like selfies and you know you can't but
each of the dancers got to choose their
own music and one girl chose like
literally the whole soundtrack from
burlesque I might have a theremin no no
it was so abbreviation and she was
reading like a best cake frock like she
was
she really she got all my money
shouldn't even show titties like she put
in time effort and thought into her act
oh I love that
speaking of musical Monday's tonight
want to come no okay but thank you for
asking
one day I'm gonna get you to come in
you're gonna have such a great time
here's the thing like I said it before
and I'll say it again like I don't care
what kind of shape I'm in I will never
go to Seoul's I go until they get new
seats well we're doing a class yeah I
know um you're not doing it no I'm like
a motivator you're gonna bring your own
BYOC
I'll bring maybe I'll bring my swipes
what is the but Schweppes
nobody Schwimmer Shh win Schwinn swimmer
swim sure yeah I'll bring my Schwinn
okay okay
anyways they're really happy for Megan
and Harry and I'm so excited and like I
feel like just the world is so [ __ ] by
this like it was my whole instagram feed
this morning and it's like it's only
gonna get crazier like I thought their
wedding was crazy and now like every
time she steps out with a bump it's
gonna be like a whole segment on 60
minutes yeah which I feel like is it
really even what she wants no but it's
no life she goes yeah and you know what
I think that it's actually is what she
wants so if we yeah I mean Deal or No
Deal royal family paparazzi yeah yeah no
question um speaking of the royal family
there was a royal wedding this weekend
and I didn't even realize how much like
I enjoyed it and like how much everyone
would care right because her mom is
Fergie right right who's like a disgrace
whose divorce from Prince Andrew is that
what she's a disgrace um yes and then
there was like something with like feet
or something I don't know very strange
but it's crazy because it's it's to to
disgrace Fergie's right to forgets who
disgrace their country so don't name
your kids hurt me but uh Princess
Eugenie is like just as close to what
you call her Eugenie that's even not to
mean not Eugenie she's not a you genie
in a bottle
no she's a usually a model what if
Eugenie
no it's you Ginny well you know you
Jimmy Jackie just swing it pertinent is
one of the jokes God said last night
he's like it's really hard to do
American shows because I'm always
emphasizing the wrong part of the word
like he's like vacation and he's
vacation you know so Eugenie Eugenie
yeah she's just coming this
but she's just as close to the Queen as
Prince Harry is like she's the Queen's
granddaughter so it really is a big deal
but so why do people care more about
because they're first in line to the
throne but why because because Ernest
got it and I think Prince Andrews like
the third and we're the kitty Spencer
fall Kitty Steiner is Harry's cousin on
the other side so she's not royal but
she's royal bye bye so nice that's the
best kind of royal cuz it's like you got
invited to the wedding hall get packed
but then like she goes on to lead her
like life of luxury and I found her an
Instagram me too
she just gets all the perks and none of
the responsibilities right like she gets
to like fly private and like go to Dolce
Gabanna in Italy but like she won't be
hounded by paparazzi like if she's just
gonna grab a coffee right and she can go
grab her own puppy like she's a credit
card right but I feel like Princess
Eugenie on the other hand gets like all
the responsibilities and none of the
perks I couldn't agree it's like she
doesn't get to be in line for the throne
and then I was when I was obsessed with
the crown I was like watching all this
documentaries on the family and I guess
like Prince Charles that's Harry's dad
right yeah
Prince Charles like I don't like him no
one likes him right yeah because he also
made the decision to consolidate the
family cuz for so long it was like the
aunts and the uncles Nietzsche says and
the cousins Nietzsche says like they
were all part of the royal family but
now it's very nuclear its Charles
Camilla has immediate family its
immediate family only and like the
cousins and stuff only get brought in
like for the one photo at the Royal
Wedding right so you to be like has to
get like Patton is treated like a royal
on negative side but then doesn't get
her own cards no I actually definitely
don't have a credit card I don't know
there's no way and if you look in every
movie like they're always like making
jokes about Eugenie and her sister like
I feel like in another cinderella story
like those two sisters right this except
sisters yeah and also um in what a girl
wants yes look those two sisters who
like throw the ball there yeah I feel
like she is so nice like I get there's
so many characters but like I mean you
see her eyes like this weenie but like
she showed up the second dress there's a
show that first of all the first dress
like stat is Queenie vibes that is royal
and it was custom Peter pilato which is
like not a lot of people know the
designer Peter Prado but like I have a
few things by him and they're just so
cute and tail
and perfection like that was such an
inspired choice and it was like class a
but elegant but also a little sexy with
a sexy back and she showed off her
scoliosis car like cher eked very
empowering beautiful the second dress
see you see her husband he's like his
glasses on for when she walked down the
aisle
so he could see her bring it Oh put up a
picture yeah oh you just find one and
text it to me um oh that's okay no that
is so cute he's so hot but that second
dress where she doesn't have a waist
like it's Larry the tobacco thing ever
snatched as [ __ ] like they're making a
sequel to snatch with Amy Schumer yeah
princess eugenie in her waist it was
stunning but also like so classy and
elegant and kept the long sleeve vibe
and it was like very fanatic like it
looked similar to the first one inspired
by an English Rose I heard in blush dead
like they looked close her husband like
what does he do so he his name is Jack
he's um like a I guess technically a
commoner Lou but he he has a good job I
don't think there's any more insulting
of a word than commoner then he's a
regular man about town no he's a
businessman but he is a businessman but
he's like similar like a level I feel
like of Pippa Middleton's husband for
sure she's popping like literally oh
yeah she's like just crazy that like
Pippa is invited to everything when
she's just the sister of Kate like I
thought this say she didn't need to be
invited to Kate's husband's cousin's
wedding I was trying to think of the
same okay so that is like hang on
that is like snitch being invited to
Ben's cousin's wedding yes we are weird
yeah that's that's like unnecessary and
especially considering this was a
smaller wedding technically than Megan
did you see the celebs that were invited
a premium yeah and it was like the
younger sect from like Megan but it's
just so odd like who was chosen to mean
by Lagoona I'm 100% sure that like Naomi
Campbell has never spoken a word to you
Jenny was she there yes and or Ellie
Goulding maybe no Ellie Goulding for
sure amara
cara for sure cuz they're all like
around the same age I definitely were
like hitting the clubs together and like
Demi Moore has never spoken to Eugenie
in her life no but I'm sure that we have
to figure out the connect
but it was cute to see like the younger
British royal size post like the
Victoria Beckham's James mornin it's
like the younger generation and diverges
and they really cane up came through
yeah no everyone looks great did you see
it was such a windy day that everyone's
hats for blowing off with the pop
nobody'll see there's videos of a
glittery people's things going flick
flying oh wow yeah it was funny that is
funny oh I saw you Jimmy was like in the
wind but yeah she the pictures were so
good I was so impressed by her yeah no
me too she you know what it is it's like
she really it has royalty in her in her
blood like it's just and that's the
difference between like even Kate or
Megan where it's like every time they do
something right we're like wow that was
amazing for you Jimmy like she was just
like brought up this way so trends she
just like is royalty oh my god speaking
of it because you just remind me of
something like nature versus nurture I
finished them to be three identical
changers because I'd only watched half
of it on the plane but they have it on
Delta but just like the various don't
spoil it because it will be a toast
movie how do you say that no and I'm
going to but I just
I'm still on room pit no it is such a
[ __ ] upsetting movie I know it is
it's like [ __ ] social experimentation
dr. mengele as hell like I got dr. Bob
and that's what they were talking about
like literally they're like these are
Nazis it's like the Jews survived the
Holocaust just to be socially
experimented on by doctor Newbauer
[ __ ] rotting in hell like worse than
Act RESPA teman oh my god nobody's
person doctors Kevin I hate actors have
Margo sent me a picture of his eye he's
my least favorite character his glasses
on oh my God he's so cute let me see he
wasn't bad he's so cute that's such a
cute move like yes and that doesn't feel
like pre-planned or staged like that's
not a thing that's like done it's not a
cliche yeah like he put his glasses on
so he could see her and you know what
she looked fine as hell and like I want
to see her and someone caught got a clip
of Fergie like rolling her eyes in like
a sigh of relief when the wedding was
over like a classic mother like my
daughter's finally married and it's so
funny he's so relatable
that's so sick such a Jewish mom thing
to do you know I'm sure like Fergie was
she was like glad to be included like
here she is like with the royal family
and they sure haven't been there in so
long
no so who is um who's your genies sister
Beatrice Beatrice and what is she up to
she's on our idea right she is
eugenie older I feel like Beatrice is
older but I just that's a feeling I
don't know for sure well I'm happy for
everyone there's so many super close
happening in the royal family I know but
I feel like we only hear about this in
class like we never hear about the bad
news actually I guess I Princess Diana
Thomas Markel there is bad news
ya know and there's definitely like a
lots of news we don't hear about for
sure but we will hear about it like when
the crown how far along is Meghan I'm
not sure I don't think she's that far
along like I think she just passed 12
weeks which is three months
she's definitely just interest I can
trimester and like happy 2000 weeks 12
weeks three months yeah no you can
announce so for three months yeah I feel
like I won't even announce to like five
months yeah so superstitious
except you know anyway
no but the twisties will figure it out I
was like if I'm not drinking yeah like
honestly I'm surprised the toasters
didn't have inside Intel into the next
story because it didn't prepare me now I
realize how prepared I am and like how
conditioned I am to know news before it
breaks because ariana grande and Pete
Davidson broke up and caught off their
engagement and I was shipped to the
[ __ ] core well there's the Abba
ship to the cork is like this is news
that like I predicted and like wasn't
shocked by but like I was just only
shocked at like they admitted it this
relationship was a drug-fueled sham but
I can't believe you're admitting like
yeah it was no it's like they stepped
out less than a week ago together so
like in that time it's so I feel like it
takes people like human regular people
common people so long before they break
up like where things have to get bad
before they get worse right so either
things have been bad the whole time or
they're just like Gary impulsive people
it's like Oh be on to a fight oh my
brain which obviously they are because
they got engaged so quickly but if you
are in tune with like the news and you
listen to nt like you could see how
problematic this is for so many reasons
but on the other hand it made me feel
like they were right or died even more
so it's like them against the world
everyone's rooting against them things
are gonna break up so it's like even
when they're gonna break up maybe they
would just push through it even like try
even harder to make it work totally
because they have something to prove
well auntie did a hole deep die
45-minute podcast on it and obviously I
didn't have the time to listen to it but
I did read the recap of this girl Hannah
who did it in the morning toasters group
like saving everyone so much time and
here's what she said first of all like
they're both more like like into drugs
like partying like alcohol pills before
but like them
together is so much worse and because
Pete is so insecure about like Ariana
being just like more famous more rich
more popular and more beautiful like
then him like he has gotten her even
more hooked on drugs so she becomes more
dependent on him and it it seems that
like people around her like got through
to her being like intervention vibes Ely
and we're like you need to get out of
this and I think like him him being
insecure in their relationship but then
also the Mac Miller of it all like she's
so devastated by it cuz like they were
together since she was 18 and she was
probably still in love with him like he
couldn't handle that like even more
insecurity so he was latching on even
more and she was like okay got away from
me oh my god and they say this is what
empty said that she is having an affair
with a late night host of a show Pete
was just on so toasters put together
that can only be Jimmy Fallon or Seth
Meyers where SNL no a late-night
talk-show host
what about a Colin Jost late-night talk
show a must eat she's not sleeping with
Jimmy Fallon no she totally she totally
do me that watch an interview of them
together yes it's like so weird to her
yeah I think it's Jimmy Dallas me do
know there's just like so much secrecy
going on and then you know that Pete was
in upstate New York like a couple months
ago and with his friend and they were
driving and they got pulled over and
they had drugs on them and he paid the
friend like 40 grand to say it was his
drugs and he took that money from Ariana
like he doesn't have that much money
that that makes it like the money he
depended on her for so like he was
really like wrapping her up like in all
this stuff just to keep her and she
finally I think got hip to it you know
that's what NT says I'm so sure and you
know what this like it's so crazy that
these two were probably the most
passionate like most in love like most
gung-ho for each other out of all of the
like quick engagements we've seen
recently and this makes me real like
feel like like Nick and Priyanka are
actually gonna go the distance because
there's no actual emotion there if they
can fake this forever right like when
it's so volatile alien Pete burns up hot
and quit Halley and Justin Wright Halley
and Justin they are on a downward spiral
and by the way I mean him but they're
married outright yes so they would have
to get divorce which is like a big
undertaking
yeah but she can do it actually I think
at this point you can get what's one
with in a you know minute moment oh yeah
I think he's like
well [ __ ] no the hair the key bump in
the street except auntie said that it's
not even it's not cocaine well it's a
blind but the person who was doing to
argue mistreat it's actually not cocaine
to something more like addictive which
tranquilizer train or like math do snort
meth and I know it rots Breaking Bad
know you smoked it yeah right
never know Margo but now no there's just
like there's so much going on with them
that picture the paparazzi caught of him
like doing drugs and the Daily Mail ran
in and didn't even address the drugs
they were just like he's wearing an
adidas shirt shirt click here like
that's the definition of fake news I
know and like this is where like empty
and like reality meets the fake news
that like Us Weekly publishes like is
this just like a two lovers star-crossed
and they end up or is it drug-fueled
money laundering prison like which is it
is it empty or is it sweet no but here's
the thing there's also a third character
category because there's empty there's
Us Weekly like they stepped out together
looking so cute and then there's also
like the in touch headlines like Haley
Baldwin's pregnant and so it's Justin
Bieber like the wild Haley Baldwin is
pregnant with student Baldwin's son they
make like these wild claims Oh Jennifer
Aniston and Brad Pitt are getting back
together and she's pregnant with his
baby so essentially I'm Mariana
courtyard yeah like they make these wild
claims so why not make those wild claims
like about the truth you know like if
you if you really don't care what kind
of claims you're making migrate at least
make them truthful because the truth is
actually crazier than the lies right
like we live in a world where like if
only everyone knew the truth like
because the truth is actually the best
story you'd ever see the movie the
invention of lying I did not
we've Ricky's your face it's such a good
movie oh what'd he do so the big was
Jennifer Garner yeah
either goes like everyone the world he
tells the truth then he goes to the bank
she took our computers are down to
remember how much was in your account
and he just like thinks of the idea to
not say the truth aney was I guess five
million dollars and that's how we
learned to lie and like he gets so far
this is the world we live it like the
tabloids they need to learn how to lie
you know what I mean totally
and then like people would eat it would
just help everyone like people take them
seriously like we know the the
information you
I know this is an amazing idea I just
like and when NT came on our podcast he
did the patreon episode which he put
behind a paywall because we're just like
too afraid of what Dan Schneider will
find when he gets there but oh that's
another thing NT said he said that
ariana is talking to Dan Schneider a lot
and that he's producing a show for her
which is we're gonna go back to TV
though like she could literally be in
movies if she wanted to she couldn't do
anything she wanted right
so why would she choose the Dan
Schneider of it all I don't know oh wait
what was my point was I saying I don't
know but I really need you to see a star
is born because I've been doing like a
lot of research I watched the Judy
Garland one last night and I started to
watch the Barbra Streisand one and I
have to say something really
controversial I know you don't like why
would I was in I really don't like
Barbra Streisand I like she's so
annoying and extra and like we get 3 of
an amazing voice but like I mean I don't
want to offend like so many people well
here's the thing we would be offending
ourselves so bright it's like I wish I
should love her like she's Jewish
like I'm Joyce New Yorker right unreal
voice like she's in some never got her
nose done because she wanted to be like
physically Jewish no and because she
didn't know if he would change her voice
that's the real reason oh and now I'm
like thinking back to everything I've
seen her in and funny girls an amazing
movie period but like memory gentle
Yenta what's that one
I don't know annoying with her I've
always liked a girl really bothers me
and I couldn't get past the first five
minutes of her version of a star is born
because like I couldn't this like and
we'll talk about a stars moment I just
like I couldn't believe it like yeah I
just didn't believe like she was just
like you know I mean I don't like love
her per se I really do you know I didn't
actually never really liked her except
she wanted to look like her
we like the shell made me like her cuz
look at Michelle loves her so much and
like I love Lea Michelle so much so like
if I like Lea Michelle and Lea Michelle
likes Barbra Streisand if a equals B and
B equals C then eight will see an I like
Barbra Streisand
so I see it a little bit but I
definitely understand the dislike of
Barbara she just bothers me I can't
explain it like liberate someone just
left a comment wait Ariana's into drugs
like this is what I'm saying like there
are people who like live live their
lives like believing what Us Weekly
tells them and like thinking that Selena
Gomez is really seeking I like help for
hid her anxiety you know what I mean
yeah and like then they repeat
like me who are just like - in it that I
literally detonator is gonna like I'm
gonna wake up one morning and he's gonna
be like on top of me he's gonna be done
it you'll think it's CEO that's why I
love living in an apartment building
totally me and Ben was it you when we
were driving to the mansions in Atlanta
be really literally sang to one another
like I couldn't ever live in a house
like it's just so easy for someone else
just like walk right in
I mean that's what's so great about
Cleveland it's like they have houses and
they have high-rises so you know I want
like a mansion penthouse high-rise yeah
where he had a doorman for your house
yeah but like still jump right over
that's true it's like even though we've
all seen The Bling Ring yeah even the
most protected house is like a ladder
but a bing bada boom yeah yeah it's just
a thought next story really sad an
update from a sweet story Teresa and Joe
Giudice stirs about to fight his
deportation okay so the the sisters
Giudice have taken to Instagram well the
first we had brothers Osborne and now
they're sisters Giudice to campaign for
their dad hashtag bring Joe home Milania
posted a selfie of her and her dad my
dad who is the best dad in the world
needs to come home we aren't done
fighting dad I can't believe this is
happening
I can't imagine another day without you
we are gonna do everything we can to
fight this daddy I love you with all my
heart buddy
hashtag heartbroken and then also gia
posted a photo like an old-school photo
of her and Joe we're like he looks juicy
as hell Sam with the man boobs totally
in the cigar like hey she said this is
one of my favorite pictures of me and my
dad my father is no threat to society
he's one of the most warm-hearted people
I know he would never harm a soul he
puts everyone else before himself
I know who my father is and I think many
of you do too my father did his time and
learn from his mistakes isn't being in
there supposed to make you realize your
mistakes you can become a better person
and that's exactly what my father did he
hasn't felt or looked this good since he
was in his 30s we have so many plans to
do as a family when he gets out I need
my father to be here my father belongs
with us and his entire family my father
came into this country when he was 1
years old the United States is the only
country he knows spread the word hashtag
bring Joe home
wait that's still crazy I didn't know
that he's been there since he was 1 I
thought he was like 12 you know yeah
that is so crazy and like honestly this
is so [ __ ] up and it seems like the
judge I'd like whoever made the decree
like just like hates Bravo Turanian no
are there like Team Caroline right oh my
god
this has Caroline Manzo written all over
it no or they're just trying to make an
example out of a celebrity like you
don't get special treat because you're
celebrities and then it's like you
actually are getting special treatment
just on the up on that opposite side
right like if he was just a regular Joe
Schmo he might not have been deported
like and that's true I feel like nobody
realizes like okay you can like do
something bad and then like be sorry for
it and like spending time in prison like
really I'm 100% sure of Joe Giudice will
never steal from the government again
like there's nothing more nothing makes
you learn a lesson more than like gangs
you know yeah I were just like being in
prison so like first of all you're
allowed to make a mistake and learn from
it and like spend time in prison and
then like be a better person so like but
that's what she's saying like isn't the
point of prison like to go to prison
rehabilitate yourself and they'll let
you out once they feel like you are no
longer like a deemed a threat or
whatever yeah you know the funniest
comment what Kim Kardashian needs to
come to his rescue I'm granting clemency
this is the prison reform that he's
fighting for episode with ellsbury
Johnson coming they keep teasing them
and it's like dr. Doleman is a free man
so it was a total wash except there was
more art than boy oh my god
it's the funniest thing it's up there I
tied with was half crazy no it's not
tied with because Todd kraines is the
funniest but like because Todd kraines
is a real person and I love him auntie
Kris it's me Todd crane and that's when
Scott was like really welcomed welcomed
into the family now he's like a
co-worker you know Todd kraines
no oh god oh my god yeah but like like
he gets so he gets paid that he does his
time he's on the show works harder than
a lot of than the Quarian Courtney but
that's something much sorry I got to
take this phone call with my attorney
we're negotiating 60 else did you see
that huh
shuri-chan yeah I got was so lame like
okay you know what that no oh my god I'm
about to make the mess analogy you know
what that's equivalent to I mean can i
least talk about this all the time when
i'm the biermann's were promoting uh
express my Lelaina they used to post
screenshots of their text messages with
the owner and like they were obviously
fake but they'd be like her name was
Regina they were like Regina please
extend the 20% off coupon like it was
literally like an act like they were
acting and that is what
60 like mocking phone call like yeah
this is my attorney were negotiating six
steals like that's the same level of
like fake acting I truly can't we do
can't shan't want okay did the final
story a little bit of tech business
legal news of course please are told to
avoid looking at recent iPhones to avoid
lockouts
law enforcement may have a challenge on
its hands police have yet to completely
wrap their heads around modern iPhones
like the X and XS and that's clearer
than ever thanks to a leaked motherboard
has obtained a presentation slide from
forensics company Elm
elcome soft telling law enforcement to
avoid looking at I phones with face ID
if they gaze at it too many times five
the company said they risk being locked
out much like Apple's Craig federighi
was during the iPhone X launch event
then they'd have to enter a passcode
which they likely can't obtain under the
US Constitution Smith amendment which
protests protect suspects from having to
provide self incriminating testimony so
that's really crazy for me personally
because I just got the new iPhone
outside of soon so like it locks and
unlocks based on my face but soon you
know if you try your passcode too many
times you get locked out so if you if it
sees your face that's not the person's
too many times like you'll get locked
out it's not up to do with the police
the police will be able to like open
people's phones oh it's just like
interesting can't they hold the phone up
to a picture of the criminal okay so
like literally when I went to dinner
with Jonathan Cheban it's totally sad
track like he only follows like 50
people on Instagram
and it was annoying me like and like
we're friends we go to general I can I
can follow me on Instagram so it's
trying to open his phone to unlock it
and get him to follow myself on
Instagram so it was literally like
following my restaurant like with his
phone in his face I try not lock it it
doesn't work oh well that's like now
girlfriends like they'll put their man's
phone in their face while they're
sleeping
okay I'll unlock it how I should do that
or you could just also try it nobody
does better than old ass Bonin you could
also get their thumb crane lobby that's
right but it's like oh you're going all
those links you've got bigger problems
right you give them a glass of water
before bed okay they drink it they put
it out and then you take it to the
kitchen and you extract the fingerprint
off the glass like he did in national
treasure that's so much harder than just
putting the taking his thumb while he's
sleeping
putting it on your phone Ben is like the
most sensitive sleeper like on Saturday
night like I had the longest day ever
traveling home from Atlanta like i
napped so I was up to literally 5:00 in
the morning and I was watching Desperate
Housewives and it was such a good climax
it was when they had the hostage
situation okay but don't spoil it
because I'm I think people have started
the show so Ben is like literally I'm
watching so low I can't [ __ ] hear
anything he rolls over me so loud like
it's Laurent volume six in the bedroom
yeah when I started we were watching and
he fell asleep oh oh not your fault
and then please I had a long travel day
like beat so like I could never grab his
thumb without him waking up he is such a
drama queen
interesting the mini house of sleeps yes
and doesn't sleep - that night - we
started like making out me and I like
stop and the next morning he was like
you told me you would let me kiss you
last night I'm like I know that you were
like try to try in your sleep and I know
you were half up and he was like no I'm
not
he said I remember he's in denial sorry
straight Eliseo zo as a witness if only
if Theo could talk by the way I ordered
you a gift and I was trying to tell you
on the phone last night and then you
were like telling you hung up on me it
was frozen and you kept talking I'm like
you didn't talking only one I can't hear
her sure but I'm just trying to tell you
that I got you an amazing it from what
website is pristine it's for you okay
it's not it's like about the Oh but it's
for you okay um from an Instagram ad
that I saw oh my god I just was like my
sister has to have this and technically
I need to get you a housewarming it's a
housewarming gift and I ordered it i
shaped it directly to your apartment so
like no muss no fuss
can we talk about that Jonathan Adler
showroom sure I didn't know that they
opened one and I didn't know that you
could like go to showrooms and buy stuff
I thought it was like for like I mean I
would hope so those sailors it said
what's in a store oh you know what I
mean for wholesale and they walked in
and it's literally just like the most
gorgeous put everything everything is so
where does that everything is so
expensive and like it was so annoying
and they had the three pieces that were
floor models they need to come out with
a diffusion line with yeah Jonathan
Adler for target Jonathan Adler for
really st. Clair there was like this
test
there was this chess set that was like
neon and it was so cute and like it was
literally ten million dollars like
everything was so expensive was making
me so mad because like they were like
three pieces that I liked and some of
them were floor models like you can get
the exact one you don't get a new one
it's like a little scratched but like it
was like a $3,000 and tray table for
$900
and it was still like too much and it
had scratches on it and like I just
couldn't spend $900 on something I'm
scratched yeah but they need to they
need to figure it out I actually would
buy something scratched like if it was a
really good discount yeah but I also
don't have a secret
I personally I'm going to scratch it but
I bought a new piece of art art Vandelay
I bought a new piece of art Vandelay I'm
really excited about it start
I know art collection that read Bristol
I would buy it just because like just
cuz with me history it would make me
smile then what aren't supposed to do
it's like supposed to make you happy and
it wouldn't make me happy every time I
passed it and like it's cute [ __ ] hmm no
a button sheep was painting that and
they framed those red and black things I
was like damn how put that over my couch
my couch is coming on Wednesday oh my
god I'm so excited I mean like I leave
Thursday for Cleveland every about Trent
like I wanted to get to sit on it no but
then we'll break it in for you pig said
we'll just break it actually no AIT's a
strong couch it's oh my god have you
seen those vintage Barbie and Ken
photographs yes and Kylie has him in her
it's called vintage Barbie oh no she has
likes about this guy's David Paris Perez
OC perhaps its first of all I was just
like doing research on mes like a studio
when he takes old Barbie dolls and the
Gloria makes mini beaches and it looks
like the beach it's so cool so cool I'm
so being Ben got we got one and if we
like it I'm gonna get another client
well so you get the prints you can buy
the prints directly from him and then
the print was like four hundred dollars
which wasn't terrible but then I have to
frame it and it's huge and like that's
gonna cost me on my way I'm gonna get
one
ya know it's so cool like I'm so excited
oh wow but like art is art you know no
and frame it's the framing well but I
looked up I wanted to get a Charles
fizzy now oh my god I thought you
already have one I do but like I wanted
more okay and I don't know where the
hell we got it and like who paid for it
because I was on art brokerage calm and
they're so expensive
I said I knew one be $2,500 I saw one at
that gallery that it took you to that
framer oh yeah I think I'm a picture on
my phone it was it was like of Times
Square
Broadway Broadway and it was the most
beautiful thing it was $25,000 oh I mean
those are galleries on Vice Adele's oh
my god there was this enormous one of
like this cute animate like this cartoon
girl in a bath and it was all covered in
rhinestones it must have been 25 feet
tall it was 50 grand and like I just
wanted it but like I don't know
where I could get 50 grand right now no
we have to we need an artist in the
family you robbed a bit because there
are some things that like you could do
yeah actually that's so funny that you
said that my friend Anna but when she
moved into her apartment in Boston she
like had this really cute like love
thing above her bed I'm like where'd you
get that just like I made it yeah there
are some things that I've seen or like I
once I was in next at the gallery way I
got you're at Theo thing and they saw
like a french fries McDonald's french
fries and it was like done in crystals
so like I I could print out a large sing
a french fries like paint it red and
yellow and then like by like stick on
crystals from Amazon and like make it
and Louden and once you put in the frame
like everything looks nice I think
remark man everything looks nice in a
frame so I feel like we should do a
crafts arts and crafts and then also
that's where the hard to do it on
vacation that we're like premium as hell
and like sort of look like slim errands
you got a frame bridge would it be weird
if I like frame to glamorous picture of
me that Jack took so it's like I mean
once you start framing photos of
yourself it's like a lovely celebrity
no she ruins framing photos herself she
put them on canvas that is a big
difference canvas is cheap as [ __ ] and
like hooker really go to frame bridge
yes okay so you've been like upload
pictures from your thing and they send
you like frame did you guys make it out
okay I call it I was people should I
should frame rates for me when I was
like trying to reframe something it's
like I'm not gonna ship this thing
that's no you don't you be you upload a
photo that works for me yeah okay
I'm gonna do it maybe oh my god I got
amazing pictures from my show in it in
Atlanta like with the audience like
maybe I would frame like a big-ass photo
of myself like put it above my bathtub
oh also like my engagement photos should
be framed yeah I got one already that I
post on my Instagram that's so premium
and the rest are coming this week and
I'm so excited I just like I want it at
my apartment what did you say I mean
like I can't believe how much effort you
put in and like the fact that you
weren't sweating is like miraculous that
I was there a few pictures where you can
tell but it's better when he turns the
signing because you're man it's like all
the sweat is gone especially when you
just got your neck done for sure yeah
yeah I'm like I'm proud of my neck I'm
proud of it too
now it's just like a good neck show over
here ya know this is the morning neck
was that the last story that was the
last story we just really breeze through
them because I feel like when the
stories are good it's like there's just
so quick because there's not much to say
like right Pete and Ariana are done I
can't I still Kent and chance believe it
like I have to wake up
even remind myself and I know it's like
meeting bug I'm happy I'm just like cuz
that I feel like justified that the
farce is be is is being called out I'm
just like worried about her and I'm
worried about him I'm worried about him
I'm worried about I don't know when we
reset on our podcast that if Ariana ever
broke up with Pete he might try it he
would like people need to wouldn't need
to watch out for him well we did that
too like he should be on suicide watch
but like yeah oh my god I'm just so
worried about with him I just feel like
she at least has like scooter and her
like mom and a ton of money and Frankie
and her grandma yeah she is like a
really good support a support system
where is he gonna live like that 15
million dollar apartment that they live
in in Chelsea like is hers I don't know
he's conniving but they like moved in
together it's like a new apartment like
he's gonna feel he move his furniture
out did they buy it or their like they
bought it and she was not furniture sex
she won't be a problem they had a few
yeah that's true but like so tumultuous
no should get rid of that apartment
of course like just bad memories and
like she can never go to Whole Foods
again no and she would sell it like for
so much more cuz now it's a literate
cultural landmark yeah but it's also
like enemies like fraught with paparazzi
and fans so maybe maybe less yeah I
don't know I don't know celebrities live
in townhouses like Madonna lives in a
townhouse Taylor Swift no shields in the
department no but she's building a
townhouse where I don't know where but
she's moving she's connecting two
together no she bought the townhouse and
next door so she can use the garage and
then connected her apartment up top to
the top so she doesn't even have to end
like she can drive in but she can leave
her house without being seen when the
construction sound like she can get into
her car in her house and then drive to
the street it's like really yeah but
it's an apartment building where like a
bunch of slippery's live and it's like
there's only like four or five floors
and I just can't imagine being a
celebrity in New York and living in a
type of a home where like there's a
front door yeah that's what my Dominick
but then I feel like I never see
somebody's who live in townhouses like
paparazzi photos of them you know I've
never seen well I'd only celebrity I
know who lives in a townhouse is Madonna
oh and Sarah Jessica Parker and Matthew
Broderick luminita people don't take
pictures of them at their house really
yeah well they're not also like Taylor
Swift's like paparazzi waiting you know
that's Mary Jo the paparazzi could live
without the photo of Matthew Broderick
do you thinks that's just a good feeling
I was watching something as
in this week what was it dirty rock I
don't know no oh yes what was he Oh Oh
Hugh and Jack Donaghy goes to work on
Washington and he's like this is living
he like runs a department where no one
works and there's no pegs and there's
Lee cousins oh my god it's so funny oh
my god I gotta get back to 30 rock it's
such a great show it is so this week but
just a little housekeeping it'll be here
Monday to Thursday are you here sir
no no I've cleveland okay I'm gonna get
a co-host and I'll be doing the show
this week pending visit
there's no Wednesday night migraine I'll
get Ben then Friday movie for my
bachelorette party I'm so excited and
instead of chewing it's gonna be I'm
actually getting nervous of how like
crazy lit it's gonna be because only
because your friends are crazy
my friends are crazy and they like bring
out the crazy and like all of this it's
so true and then we're just like
operating at a level of just wild right
you like when you're relaxed like you
bringing out the granny and everyone but
like between Daniel and Margaux you in
like everyone together like just like
loving one another and we never get to
be together that much it like it's just
gonna be crazy it's just going to be
crazy and like we haven't taken a trip
in a while look at that beach vacation
we actually not since Turks the scenes
at least you know that was like pretty
recently though like it was this year
that was the Marcus wedding it was just
a mix Megan Marco got pregnant married
and pregnant in the time that well must
be nice yeah so much going on though you
were just in Mexico so what's going on
in the world these days if only there
was a premium morning show that kept
everyone had to break it all down for
you well here's the thing thanks for
tuning into the morning toast the
Millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube and Facebook but soon
only YouTube's make sure to subscribe on
youtube starting on November 28th the
only YouTube but better
yeah you're also following us on
Instagram because we have just like peak
content at all times like breaking news
literally breaks on the morning shows
Instagram so it's very important that
you follow us there and everywhere else
at the morning toast and it's been
absolutely lovely spending time with you
if you're a podcaster you can tune in
every day make sure to subscribe to us
i'm spotify itunes stitcher or anywhere
else you can listen to podcasts I don't
really know public radio since you like
that thank you so much for being here
and just being wonderful participants in
this beautiful Monday morning show I'm
Claudia Oscar a girl with her job thank
you so much for being here
I'm Jackie ah hey Jackie Oh problems
thank you for being here we will see you
tomorrow
you